you see I believe that life is really
very simple what we give out we get back
and what we believe about ourselves
becomes true for us our thinking creates
our experiences there is a law of
thinking like everything else like all
of nature there is a universal energy or
law of mind or subconscious mind
whatever you want to call it but to me
it means the power that is within me and
around me transforms my thoughts into
experiences you see I believe that we
are all responsible for everything in
our lives every thought we think and
every word we speak is creating our
experiences our future and it's almost
as though every time you think a thought
or you speak a word that Universal
intelligence or energy is listening or
responding to what you are thinking or
believing or saying without judgment or
criticism totally accepting us at our
own value whatever we choose to believe
becomes true for us
this whole thing about abundance and
attracting to yourself what it is that
you want and how to use mantras and
spirituality to make sure you have what
you want true spirituality is about not
wanting is about being filled with joy
from inside and then sharing that
outside it's not about attracting to
yourself what you want people ask me is
there a law of attraction yes and you
better be scared of it because if it's
true that you attract what your mind is
thinking you better take a look at what
your mind is thinking what about your
mind all day when it's complaining and
it's yelling at people and it doesn't
like stuff but if you're attracting that
way so you eventually catch on that it
is not about getting what you want it is
about learning to find out that what you
really want is to stay open and not have
conditions on that openness and then it
comes down to how do you do that are
people capable of doing that or is that
just reserved for you know some special
beings Buddha and Christ that have
walked the face of the Earth everybody
is capable of that if I tell you to pick
up five thousand pounds you may not be
able to do that so I've told you to do
something that you have never done and
you're not doing it so you may not be
able to do it but if you're actually
already doing something and I tell you
not to do it you're always capable of
that because you're the one who's doing
it
the power to manifest is in experiencing
the fullness of the present moment the
undifferentiated fullness what Jesus
called life in its fullness in one of
the translations I want you to have life
in its fullness he said and that is not
stuff he's not referring to things life
in its fullness isn't in a state of
being it is to experience to know to
realize the being is within you the I am
it is consciousness itself that is life
that is the fullness of life in the
words of Jesus the fullness of life you
you know yourself as Consciousness once
you know that then no future moment can
possibly be better anything that can
happen in the future isn't adding on to
one of the things that really upset me
for a long time was the fact that I had
great ideas and intentions and I wanted
to manifest them and I thought this is
how it's going to manifest and so I had
all these visions of how things were
going to unfold and then I'd started
processing it wouldn't unfold and then
it would irritate me because like I've
got to make it work I gotta make it work
ultimately I started to recognize when
things didn't work it was possibly
because there were better ways to do it
and I wasn't conscious of it and so what
I started to learn over a period of time
was simply this there's an old saying
there's a means to an end and the idea
well the end is your destination and of
course the means are how you're going to
get to that destination well of course
all of us sit down and say yeah this is
what I want and then we start to figure
out well this is what I'll do to get to
those ends I'll get to this and I'll get
to this to get to the end what I started
to realize at some point was maybe my
awareness of how to get to the end
wasn't exactly accurate and it turns out
many of the times when things didn't
work and I was like so upset it didn't
work but it turned out oh there was a
better way to get there and I didn't
even know it so the universe was really
facilitating me and I wasn't paying
attention I was getting angry at the
universe because like it's not working
in a way I want it to work and then I
started to realize some point was my God
maybe the universe has a better solution
than the one I was even thinking of
myself hi I'm Bruce lithon author of the
best-selling books the biology beliefs
spontaneous Evolution and the honeymoon
effect I'm here to thank Evan Carmichael
for featuring me on his YouTube channel
and I want to let you know that Evan is
giving away links where you can watch
the First episodes of my special Gaia
series entitled in a revolution for free
evidence making this offer to thank you
for watching this video you will find
the links in the description section
below thank you do less and attract more
today I actually had this experience I'd
said notice something that I really
wanted to do old Gabby would have 100
000 freaking percent pushed herself made
that the whole thing happened
reorganized her entire schedule just
pushed push post put herself into some
maybe some uncomfortable sort of chaotic
time constraints just to get that thing
done to maximize
and yeah I probably would have gotten
something out of it and it would have
been valuable but at my own expense it
would have been potentially exhausting
it would have taken me out and that
doing might have kept me from some
really important allowing we have this
sense often that the more we do the more
we'll succeed
I could not be more the opposite for me
in this instance now I'm realizing 22
years behind me 16 years as a spiritual
teacher 22 years as a spiritual
entrepreneur
and see and look back and say I wish I'd
done some a little less and to be clear
I wouldn't change anything because I do
genuinely believe that the Universe has
a plan for us and even the things that
we wish we'd known if we had known them
something different would have happened
but moving forward I'm going to really
apply do less and attract more
because the more we push and hustle and
try to be everywhere and be everything
and say yes to everything the last
energy we have for creativity the less
space we have for cultivating the
creative mindset that we need to allow
inspired ideas to move through us
the less space that we have to let the
universe give us Direction and show us
where to go and what to do most people
try to create a new personal reality as
the same personality and it doesn't work
we literally have to become someone else
in other words thoughts are the language
of the brain and feelings are the
language of the body and how you think
and how you feel creates a state of
being so most people have experiences in
their life that brand them emotionally
they feel fear they feel anger they feel
bitterness they feel frustration they
feel insecurity and those emotions then
become part of their identity so once
they think certain thoughts that turn on
certain circuits in their brain that are
equal to their insecurity and then they
feel insecure the moment they feel
insecure they think more insecure
thoughts which makes more chemicals for
them to feel insecure and the repetition
of that cycle over time conditions the
body to subconsciously become the mind
of insecurity so then the person says I
am insecure and whenever you say I am
anything you're commanding your mind and
body towards a destiny
don't Focus too much on where you are
now because guess what your potential
expands As you move towards it you know
what that means it means you can never
know what your potential is because as
you move towards it it expands so you
may think I just want to get a job on a
kitchen I'd love to work in the kitchen
cooking and as you start everything
actually I'd like to be the senior Chef
in this kitchen and that will move to I
want my own restaurant I want my own
cookery book I want my own cookery
program there's nothing wrong with any
of that one of my clients just wanted to
be a vet that's all she wanted to be but
she couldn't be a vet because she was
asked to leave veterinary school twice I
said look it isn't black or white why do
you want to be a veteran I love animals
I just want to work with animals and so
I spoke to her and asked her to consider
working in a charity for animals and
then she trained to be an animal
behavioral expert and then she got her
own show so her pretend Central went
from working in this animal rescue
center being paid to work in an animal
rescue center training to be an animal
behavioral expert all because that was
what her heart wanted to do that's all
she ever wanted to do keep thinking
about your goals use that mood one
remember your potential expands As you
move towards it where you are now it
doesn't matter you have no idea what
your potential is because it's going to
move as you move towards it I like to
dialogue with my mind now that sounds
quite funny to say that you have a
dialogue and a conversation with your
mind but anybody that does deep work
with their mind whether through
meditation whether through mind power is
that you find is that your mind is
talking to you all the time it's telling
you things it's commenting it's too cold
today or I don't like the people that
I'm with or I wish I had more money or
isn't this a delicious meal so your mind
is constantly commenting and has a
narrative and is thinking all the time
and it's very valuable to first of all
know that and observe it because one of
the very first teachings that I give is
that you are not your mind and to
realize that you're not your mind that
your mind is a part of you and a very
important part of you a very valuable
part of you but it's only a part of you
you are much Beyond simply your mind and
your mind talks to you all the time you
get to talk to your mind as well
I want to just tell you about
manifestation because it's effortless
it's light and it's effortless there's
no effort involved when you're fighting
when you're pushing you don't believe
that you have what you're wanting it's
not going to come you're going to keep
creating not having it because you're
creating all the time so you're either
manifesting it or you're creating not
manifesting it or the absence of it so
manifestation is like I once used to
think that it's as light as a feather so
there's this effortless feeling that you
have inside of you when you want to
manifest it's just like this feeling of
peace and happiness and you just know
that it's going to come and you know
that a single thought that you focus on
will manifest you have all power to
manifest whatever you want all power and
so if you don't believe in the power
that you have then you're going to
really push and pull ocean pool and
fight the one thing you need if you want
to move higher
is a greater a limbs
[Music]
people are not earning a hundred
thousand a year because I want to earn
100 000 a year thirteen hundred thousand
a year because they're not aware of how
to earn a hundred thousand a month
people aren't alone and lonely because
they enjoy being alone and lonely
they're alone and lonely because they're
not aware of how to build meaningful
relationships
people don't struggle all of their
commercial career because they enjoy
struggling they're struggling because
they're not aware of how to knock those
blocks down that are all inside it's
never outside it's never another person
it's never a condition or a circumstance
it's always lack of awareness
this is such beautiful information
I've been living with it for a long time
I don't even know how you'd live without
it
in fact I don't think you can you merely
exist and unfortunately that's the way
most people go through life
you see our educational institutions is
not giving us the same kind of
information they really don't they
really believe the secret is read the
book remember what's in the book and be
able to repeat it answer the questions
more right than wrong you'll pass you
get the degree well we've got people
graduating from some of the most
prestigious universities in the world
every year
[Music]
with multiple degrees
they're having difficulty finding work
that are broke how does that happen
and yet you'll find other people who are
functioning illiterate they can either
read or write they were earning Millions
how do we account for this
you're going to find that out as you
study this it's got nothing to do with
anything outside of ourselves
education isn't answering what's in the
book education comes from the Latin new
Juco meaning to reduce to developer to
draw from within remember I said
everything's already here omnipresent
that's within us
Madame Montessori was right Napoleon
Hill was right
Carnegie knew the right question
Hill knew how to answer it what are you
going to do with the rest of your life
[Music]
that's your question you're going to
make a decision
there's a lot of ways that people block
their manifestations and I want to call
them out right now I hear this from so
many people Gabby I'm doing it all I'm
meditating I'm praying I'm setting
intentions creating vision boards but
I'm not manifesting one reason you're
not manifesting is because you don't
believe in what you're trying to
manifest
when you believe it you'll receive it
but if you don't believe it then you're
just trying pushing control and try to
make something happen that isn't fully
ingrained in your presence in your being
in your energy
and so you have to do your part to get
into the belief system of knowing that
this is indeed
something you are worthy of so how do
you get into that grounded belief system
create a vision statement a statement
that claims that your desire is on the
way that you are worthy of what it is
that you desire ground yourself in that
statement focus on it and instead of
focusing on the outcome focus on the
feeling of what it is to believe and
know that you are worthy of your desire
if you're wanting to attract a romantic
partner into your life a vision
statement could sound like I believe I'm
worthy of the love that I desire where I
believe that I am ready to receive that
romantic relationship in the perfect
time in order say that vision statement
daily for at least 40 days get yourself
grounded in the belief you have to
believe it to receive it the next reason
you're not manifesting
because you're trying too hard
I'm sorry to say it but it's true the
more you push the more you control the
more you try the more you affirm the
more you vision board the more the more
the more the less you receive if you're
pushing and you're controlling and
you're trying to make something happen
if you are completely out of alignment
with the universe you're not aligned
with that freedom that presence of Love
The Art of allowing rather than doing
forcing making happen
yeah we have to show up for our lives
but we can't force our dreams to become
a reality so the key here is to let go
so here's your message the secret to
manifesting is to forget what you think
you need let it go how do you let it go
with this intention
thank you Universe for guiding me to
what is of the highest good for all when
you make it about the highest good and
not about what you think you need then
the universe can truly show up for you
you can relax and allow even more than
you could imagine to enter into your
life
and here's another reason that you're
not manifesting this is going to be
tough for you to hear
because you're not vibrating at the
right frequency
what do you mean well what I mean is
that you're leaning into the negative
you're judging a lot you're focusing on
scary things that make you so anxious
and you just keep focusing on them and
dwelling on them you're obsessed with
worrying you love to overthink things
look I understand that behavior more
than anyone could imagine I'm a
recovering Warrior I'm a recovering
anxious person I've been there I
understand that but when we are not in
that vibration that's relaxed released
at ease present
we're actually blocking our
manifestations because that low Vibe
energy is blocking our high Vibe
attracting power so what do you do focus
on the good stuff
lean into the positive look for
Solutions rather than problems stop
yourself when you notice that you're
being judgmental or gossipy hang out
with people that make you feel good do
things that make you feel good lean
towards joy and you will be led
when you dwell in that energy of Joy the
universe will deliver so if you're not
attracting what you desire just relax
it's all good focus on these methods
notice when you're out of alignment and
come back to this video practice one of
these methods use these tools ground
yourself back into alignment believe it
to receive it feel good and it will come
to you naturally we have the power
within us to attract what we desire when
we allow our internal condition to
reflect what we want to attract on the
outside so make that your highest
priority a lot of people
who watched me and the other teachers in
the movie The Secret
I think simplified the law of attraction
into thinking that all you've got to do
is you know think about making more
money believe that you can achieve
earning more money
and then more money is going to be
attracted to you somehow through some
mysterious process
almost as if you know thinking and
believing is the only thing that's
needed in order to make the money that
you want to make
and I think a lot of people were set off
on the wrong path to making the Law of
Attraction work for them and so let me
give you a couple of things on how you
can exponentially attract more money
through understanding a little bit more
about energy a little bit more about the
process of manifestation so if you're
ready
when we go to the fundamental fact that
everything is energy you are energy the
computer or cell phone you're watching
me on is made up of tiny little bits of
photons vibrating packets of energy we
call that quanta
but if it was just enough to you know to
think and believe you know that money is
going to be attracted to you everybody
would be rich wouldn't they they'd have
beautiful houses nice cars they go on
vacations everywhere and there would be
a financial abundance windfall for
everybody but why do most people who
believe in the Law of Attraction not end
up being rich financially
and the answer is it's a little bit more
complex than the surface of what was
covered in the movie so let me give you
a couple of things to think about and do
when we're dealing with money you've got
to remember yes money is just an idea uh
we use uh coins and chocolates and
seashells and livestock and we Bartered
and traded you know one thing for
another like bread for teeth cleaning or
working on a horse's Hooves you know for
something that somebody else needed in a
small village or town so going back in
time to the beginning you know when we
even came up with this concept of money
money was created as a means of exchange
between people money wasn't ever thought
of as something that just popped into
your lap or into your life just because
you were meditating or visualizing you
know or hoping and praying and wishing
that you had more money it's a means of
exchange however there are some things
to focus on
if money is energy and let's call that
the spiritual side of energy and we know
that there is more than enough money for
everybody there's there's uh signs of
money and you know in cash and coins and
Golds and buildings and real estate
in products and services that represent
money we know there's more than enough
of it
the key to getting the Law of Attraction
into uh into motion is thinking of it
slightly differently and instead of
thinking of the Law of Attraction
something that you know is attracted to
you like a magnet
think of it as the law of resonance
something that when you become in
resonance with
then there is more than enough and so
the question is
how do I become in resonance with more
money so first and foremost I want to
teach you a model called semp
s-e-m-p and it stands for Spiritual
emotional mental and physical
and since you're into the Law of
Attraction you probably believe that
everything is energy and that there is a
spiritual side to your being and and a
governance of this incredible you know
universe and planets Etc
so let's assume that the spiritual
intelligence is within you and within
everybody else and in all things in all
places at all times it's omnipotent and
omnipresent right and as I say this my
Chimes are dinging maybe that's because
that's the truth
well what if that's the beginning of the
Law of Attraction get in resonance with
abundance get in resonance with the
genius Part of Yourself get in resonance
with the people the tools the resources
that are here right now that will help
you achieve more income more wealth part
one part two is the E part of Seb
emotions what if
you got emotionally connected to
achieving the financial goals that you
want to have what if you picked a
financial goal that you wanted to
achieve and then you started to feel as
if that was already happening is it
possible
that by getting emotionally connected to
that money to that wealth to that income
you're increasing the amplitude of the
vibration of you your 100 trillion cells
governed by your brain which we'll get
to in a minute and is it possible if you
have a financial goal and you see
yourself in your mind's eye and you feel
yourself achieving that Financial goal
that you can become in Harmony in
resonance with that income that goal is
it possible just think for just a moment
I'll wrap it all up in about three or
four minutes so the S is the abundance
the E is the emotion now let's get into
mindset
your mental faculties earlier we
mentioned you know think and believe
but what happens if you believe that
it's possible but you also believe that
maybe you're too young or too old or
maybe you believe you don't have the
knowledge or the skills or maybe you
believe that you know it's easy for
other people but not for you or maybe
you believe you don't have the education
or maybe you believe that you don't
deserve it or maybe you believe
um that it's not the right timing if you
have a positive desire goal or vision
and you have disempowering limiting
beliefs or a self-image that doesn't
really really believe that you deserve
it what may be happening is that you are
not in coherence or in Harmony in your
mind and in your heart
and that means that even though you may
be sending out these signals okay for
the abundance the money the income the
wealth that you want if either at the
neurological level the Heart level or
the gut level you don't really really
really believe for whatever reason that
you can achieve that goal or have that
goal goal or have that lifestyle then
you are creating a chaotic vibration
between your physical body your emotions
your mindset and in this field of
intelligence shall we call it so so far
we've talked about spiritual emotional
mental and I've only touched scratched
the surface of this but now let's talk
about the physical side of it do you
remember earlier
I suggested that we developed money as a
means of exchange between people
companies governments Etc well
if you want to have more money
the question now becomes are you doing
the right things in the right order in
the physical world to be able to create
this circle this this exchange mechanism
where you are providing your product
your knowledge your services to others
in exchange for money
you see when people aren't in total
resonance spiritually emotionally
mentally and physically
chances are that the Law of Attraction
will not work for them and since we Are
Spiritual Beings having a human
experience and we have emotions and we
are able to control our mental models
and our mindset we can control the fears
that we have of failure or being
disappointed or embarrassed or shamed or
ridiculed because those are the things
that hold us back from achieving our
financial goals and life goals
the more you learn how to get
incoherence in harmony
the easier making more money becomes and
most people are never taught this
Advanced model called semp so that they
can earn more have more live more give
more be more
and they keep thinking that the law of
attraction is think believe and you'll
achieve that's baloney
there are a variety of advanced
methodologies that you can learn to get
into total Harmony total coherence with
earning two times three times four times
five times more income having the wealth
that allow you to have the financial
Freedom the choice freedom to pursue the
things that you really want to pursue in
your life once I discovered
neuroplasticity I thought I wish I'd
known about this when I was 18. really
you know it's literally life-changing I
think I was naturally manifesting from
about the age of 18 anyway but I didn't
understand the science behind it once
you understand that you can literally
change your brain at any stage any age
any mindset
that's like
it's life-changing isn't it and and I
feel that you know one of the things we
were sort of chatting about earlier is
that just because I'm a scientist and an
MD it doesn't mean that in my real life
it's easy for me to just Channel
neuroplasticity it's still it's still
hard you know I've been through a
divorce I've been through grief I've
been through career change
and
those Hard Times taught me resilience
and neuroplasticity
but the hard times were almost the
opportunity I didn't want to go through
those things I don't want you know our
listeners to go through hard times yeah
pain but
you can take that as an opportunity and
I think if you really understand
neuroplasticity then you can make the
worst times in your life the start of
the best time in your life and that's
what I love about neuroplasticity that
it's that ability to change to grow to
regulate your emotions which I know
you're really into and and build
resilience I mean an example of
neuroplasticity that I would share with
with you with our listeners is
gratitude lists
so for years in my journaling I would
write 10 things I'm grateful for every
day
and they were always external things
friends family travel you know
um Financial Freedom whatever and I
literally just got bored of writing the
same things so I thought okay what what
else could I write so I started writing
things like my creativity my
vulnerability my resilience internal
things
and that was a real game changer really
what happened when you started doing
that it made me think that whatever life
throws at me I've got the tools and
resources within me to deal with it
um and and I didn't always have you know
in my 20s
I wouldn't say I was very emotionally
regulated
um but
learning that
whatever happens the the sort of
the pendulum swing for your emotions the
higher it goes the lower it goes as well
and and bringing that to like parameters
that you're comfortable with is
that gives you sort of autonomy and
agency in life sure
um and and again that's the thing I love
about neuroplasticity because you made
it this far in a video I want to
celebrate you most people start and
don't finish most people never actually
follow through most people say they want
something but they don't ever do the
work to actually get it but you're
different you are special believe Nation
you made it here all the way to the end
and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome
to learn how to brainwash yourself for
Success check the video right there next
to me I think you'll love it continue to
believe and I'll see you there every
morning I wake up it's not just about
working out but for me working out has
been a very big part of my mental growth
so for me if I am not challenging myself
every day and I swear to God people will
not believe it I was over